ahora mismo nos encontramos en
alejandreta una ciudad en la provincia
de hatay la más afectada por el número
de víctimas por el terremoto que se
vivió hace un día en la madrugada y en
esta provincia han muerto más de 800
personas según el gobierno Turco en
edificios derrumbados como el que tengo
detrás hay dentro hay niños que venga
alguien a rescatarlos los que están
ahora no pueden levantar nada Dios mío
hay dos niños dentro porque Dios no nos
ayuda
los vecinos de este edificio denuncian
que las autoridades no han venido en
ningún momento a intentar sacar de los
escombros que aún siguen atrapadas las
personas después de más de un día bajo
las ruinas son los propios vecinos que
están llevando a cabo las tareas de
rescate todos se quejan de que están
abandonados tanto por las autoridades
turcas como las internacionales que
están completamente desbordadas con
miles de edificios como este en estas
provincias que han quedado totalmente
destruidas aquí no viene nadie estamos
todos esperando el cementerio los que
tienen a sus allegados allí dentro saben
que han muerto cualquier pregunta y
conversación sobra aquí hace falta
máquinas profesionales de los servicios
de rescate hace falta que vengan los
equipos con sus herramientas y que
saquen todos los bloques pesados sino no
hay nada que hacer en total según el
gobierno Turco más de 5.000 edificios
han quedado destruidos y varios miles de
víctimas tanto en Turquía como en el
norte de Siria
también muy afectado por este terremoto
estamos hablando del terremoto más
mortífero en Turquía del siglo XXI muy
cerca del que pasó en 1939 que dejó En
esa ocasión más de 30.000 muertos